in the history of the world there have
appeared a few rulers here and there
that have stood out among the multitude
emperors and kings whose reputation has
lasted beyond their years of rule
some of them may be famous for their
unmatched
cruelty maybe for their military prowess
or for their
diplomatic skills others are famous for
other reasons entirely let's face it
most of the rulers of history aren't
necessarily
known for their tolerance or openness
and intellectual curiosity
i can think of only a few off the top of
my head but one of those great rulers of
history
is certainly the mughal emperor akbar
sometimes also known as akbar of the
great
which actually means something like
great the great so maybe we should
just stop using that name in any case
akbar is remembered for being
perhaps the most successful and powerful
emperor
of the whole mughal empire an emperor
that expanded the empire's borders
and showed very impressive skills both
in military and
diplomatic fields but why you ask are we
talking about a political leader on a
channel about religion
well that is because akbar is not only
famous for the reasons already mentioned
but also for his very fascinating
religious
policies and approaches not only did he
show an unusual level of
tolerance and openness towards different
religious groups within the
regions that he ruled but he was also
intellectually and spiritually
engaged and interested himself he would
converse with
scholars from different religions and
even instigated a religious
movement of his own which he called the
dean ilahi or the divine
religion akbar is a very famous ruler
but also one that is often
misrepresented both by his enemies and
by his fans
so today let's dive into the world of
mughal india
in the 16th and 17th century and talk
about one of the most fascinating world
leaders in history
[Music]
was the third official emperor of the
great mughal empire
one of the three often so-called great
gun powder empires of the early modern
period
and definitely the emperor who set the
bar and established a dynasty as the
mighty force that it would become
under his leadership and afterwards in
order to fully grasp the context in
which akbad and his success is figured
it will be important and helpful to have
a general grasp of the political and
social circumstances of the mughal
empire
here is my friend siawish from the
channel al-mukhadima to explain more
about
the mughal empire pre akbar zahira deen
muhammad babur
was one of the many princes of the
murdered lineage lurking around central
asia
after failing to carve an empire for
himself there he moved to kabul
in modern day afghanistan from here he
launched raids into north india which
was being ruled by the dali sultanate
the sultanate in turn was being ruled by
the lodi dynasty which was internally
very fractured
this gave babur an opening to invade in
1525.
by 1526 he had defeated the lodhi sultan
and established the mahal dynasty in
india he died in 1530
trying to consolidate his power his son
and successor
humayun had a bit of an alcohol and
opium addiction
which paved the way for rebellions and
pretenders one such rebellion
came from the afghan general sherhan
suri who defeated humayun and overthrew
him
in 1540. humayun was pretty much
homeless when akbar was born
for the next 15 years he went from ally
to ally seeking support against the
afghans
finally the road was cleared when
shaykhan or as he was now known
died and the safavids gave their support
to humayun
humayun reconquered his former empire by
1555
though he had only ruled for six months
when he slipped and fell
from the stairs of his library and died
leaving the empire to young
deen muhammad who became known as akbar
don't forget to check out the full
channel at mokhadema which is a great
historical channel
he has also just made a video on akbar
which focuses more on the
political and military aspects of his
rule
which you can check out on his channel
right after watching this video
links are in the description another
mughal empire with its expansion and
especially
under and after the rule of akbar in
particular became a significant empire
one of the greatest empires in the
history of the indian subcontinent
it stood as one of the three major
empires of the
islamic world at the time the ottomans
which ruled
most of the middle east from istanbul in
modern turkey
uh and also the safavids in modern-day
iran
and lastly then there was the mughals in
what is today
india and pakistan to the indian
subcontinent and the mughals would rule
for a long time even after the
british occupation the mughal emperor
still sat on the throne even if they
didn't have the same amount of power
all the way up to the 19th century but
the height of their power arguably was
during and around especially a bit after
the time of akbar and his immediate
successors
akbar is certainly the most famous of
the mughal emperors
and arguably the most important he was
born in 1542 to
humayun the second mughal emperor and a
shiite mother
poetically foreshadowing his later life
of religious diversity
after he himself became emperor in 1556
akbar very quickly showed himself to be
a more than able
leader he led mary military campaigns
that extended the borders of the mughal
empire to encompass
what is most of india basically he
established his capital in
agra and later in lahore rather than
ruling remotely from afghanistan as his
predecessors had done
and he also established many
administrative systems that helped
expand
wealth of the region significantly one
interesting aspect of akbar's life is
that from his earliest years and
for the rest of his life he seems to
have been entirely illiterate
there are stories of how many teachers
in his youth would try to teach him to
read and write but
in vain there was no way that they could
teach him which has led many scholars
today to argue that he
may have been dyslectic the christian
jesuit mancerat who used to attend
akbar's court
wrote that he was quote entirely unable
to read or write
something that of course wasn't uncommon
for people in general at that time but
certainly so for the emperors of the
mughal dynasty
but despite this illiteracy akbar was an
incredibly inquisitive individual who
valued knowledge
science and spiritual insight as we will
see
he didn't let this inability stop him
from being immensely interested in all
kinds of different knowledge
akbar was throughout his life a great
enjoyer of
sports and different outdoor activities
one of his favorite pastimes was to hunt
something that many stories tell us
about
the mughals were muslims and akbar was a
muslim who
at least in the first decades of his
life that point will return to
took his religion very seriously he
performed all the obligatory rituals and
prayers and conceived of himself as the
secular leader and champion of sunni
islam
he was not only known as the shah the
king of kings
but also referred to himself as the amir
al-mu'mineen
the commander of the faithful and as the
caliph of islam
something that greatly concerned the
ottoman sultans in the west
but it certainly wasn't an entirely
unfounded claim at the height of his
power
akbar ruled an enormous population of
muslims and non-muslims
probably the largest muslim population
of all the islamic empires at that time
and yet in spite of this descriptions of
akbar and his life
paints the picture of a relatively
modest and contemplative man
concerned with spiritual matters and the
well-being of those he ruled over
now the majority of biographical
material about akbar comes from the
accounts of his grand vizier abu fazil
ibn mubarak
and his works called akbar nama and ayni
akbari
of course then abu fazal paints akbar
his boss
in the most favorable light which should
be kept in mind
we also have accounts by writers like
al-bada yuni and
ahmed sir hindi both of whom were akbar
as enemies and so
are on the other side of the spectrum
and should be approached carefully for
the same reasons
in any case the picture that emerges of
akbad is a fascinating and intriguing
one
no matter which side you are on the rule
of akbar was one in which the
mughals were trying to sort of shake off
some of their cultural
baggage or cultural background now
the moguls originally came from what is
today
referred to as persia and they spoke
persian in court etc but
the mughals ultimately descended from
the mongols
from people like the timur and so on
which is of course suggested by the name
mughals
as such they were kind of the successors
to some of the great islamicized mongol
leaders of
earlier centuries like what i mentioned
timur or tamerlane
who had ruled persia for a very long
time previously and while akbar will
often of course emphasize
this cultural heritage and be proud of
it we also see him trying to
modify or root out some practices that
were common among the post-nomadic
mongols
this included gatherings of soldiers
where excessive drinking of alcohol took
place for example
it also included the general mongol ways
of warfare which was
according to most estimates quite brutal
and unforgiving
al-badiyuni writes that quote it was the
code of genghis khan to massacre or make
slaves of
all the inhabitants of a conquered
region to destroy
utterly many towns and villages and
sweep everything clean and clear
to value god's creation as it were but
radishes
cucumbers and leaks instead in order to
conform more to islamic law and customs
of war
akbar forbade things like indiscriminate
killings of non-combatants and the free
taking and selling of slaves
he also seems to have inaugurated a very
strict court etiquette which even to his
contemporaries seemed quite extreme
the historian andrei wink writes quote
here the allegory of taming the mongol
beasts
translates into an attempt to turn a
loose multi-ethnic
and religiously heterogeneous assemblage
of post-nomadic military retainers
into a disciplined service nobility
while establishing a rigid court
etiquette
as a new force of counter-insurgency
this task was never easy since akpar
like many other rulers
could not afford to antagonize his
nobles it had to be done by a judicious
mixture
of force and persuasion just like the
taming of elephants as abu fazel says
these aspects of akpad are important to
keep in mind i think
they are important in order for us to
nuance our understanding of his later
religious policies for example
and also in order to counteract some of
the attacks
by his enemies who often wanted to
portray him or often paints him
as an irreligious liberal leader whose
relationship to islam was
shaky at best and completely
non-existent at worst
but the historical record shows that
this is simply not true
akbar in fact comes across as an
unusually
pious and moderate leader and emperor in
this
context akbar was not only a devout
muslim but also a great admirer
of the sufi saints indeed sufism at this
time was basically synonymous with islam
especially in this region
and most muslims at this time were in
some way connected to one of the
different sufi tariqas the different
sufi orders
akbar seems to have been particularly
devoted to the
shishti order of sufis which was one of
the major
sufi orders in this region in the indian
subcontinent at that time
he would perform various ziadas visits
or minor pilgrimages to the shrines of
some of the great shishti masters
like mauidin shishti in azmer and
nizamuddin auliya in delhi
both of these masters and the shishti
order in general has indeed been
characterized as a relatively tolerant
and open one
treating with respect people of
different religions which is also what
attracted many from the local population
to their teachings and helped them to
convert eventually
so when we look at akbar as a muslim we
should consider the fact that it was
this kind of islam that he was a
particularly adherent to
the shishti order of sufism something
that i think is related to his own
religious attitudes
i think it's more beneficial to
recognize that the open
and inclusive attitude that he would
hold later in life
shouldn't just automatically be seen as
a result of waning commitment to islam
or as the result of outside influence
but rather that these kinds of ideas
might have come from sincere devotion to
islam
since those kinds of tendencies do exist
within the religion itself but in any
case we do find akbar indulging in some
of the
luxuries of imperial life including the
consumption of alcohol for example
basically all emperors did drink alcohol
in most of these great empires in the
islamic world also
but with akbar in fact we find an
unusual abstaining from
alcohol more so than many other emperors
indeed akbar seems to have had a much
more aesthetic approach and
moderate approach a kind of pious
approach to how he wanted to be an
emperor and what kind of an emperor he
wanted to be
according to reports by jesuit
missionaries akbar
very rarely drank any wine and he also
went
long periods without drinking any wine
at all
the stories also tell of how akbar would
completely forbid the
consumption of alcohol and opium in his
courts and in wider society
al-khandahari writes that quotes he is
the king who escaped wine
in obedience to god's command these
general attitudes and policies don't
really fit
with the conceived image of akbar as a
non-religious apostate
he furthermore was greatly interested
and invested in spiritual matters and is
said to have had
many spiritual experiences himself
one such experience he had when he was
out hunting and suddenly had a great
insight which led him to become a
vegetarian
or at least he tried to become a
vegetarian
he would go long periods of time in his
life without eating any
meat during his fasting for example but
also
otherwise and he tells us that it was
basically only due to social pressure
that he didn't become
a full vegetarian full time so to say
quote
if the scarf of social life were not on
my shoulder
i would restrain myself from eating meat
and indeed this vegetarianism was for
religious and spiritual reasons
but we should be careful too as many
have
connect this immediately to the
practices of hinduism for example where
vegetarianism is very common
because indeed vegetarianism has been a
common practice in sufism as well
historically
and it's more likely that it comes from
there indeed akbar himself refers to
vegetarian food
as sufi food which seems to confirm this
connection
in other words we find a greatly pious
and moderate man
especially for someone of his status
it's telling that the emperors that
followed him like jahangid and shah
jahan
who are both often seen as more
quote-unquote islamic emperors
both had serious problems with
alcoholism
akbar was not that kind of emperor
abulfazal writes quote
the world is in the contemplation of the
sean charles genus
an extremely contemptible affair he does
not deem it worthy of his complete
attention
and always keeps his soul attached to
the importance of god
neither is he the kind of emperor who
would be remembered for his cruelty or
intolerance
indeed as i mentioned in the beginning
akbar showed an unusual level of respect
to the different
cultural and religious traditions of
india
or this empire generally several of his
wives were hindus
and he appointed many hindu officials
into his
court into his empire they had high
status positions
in his court akbar generally had an
approach and policy of
accepting a religious plurality in his
empire
a strategy that proves as it often does
to be incredibly successful
one story tells of how the emperor
interacted with the young sikh community
the third guru of the sikhs guru amardas
had established the practice of lankar
in gondival
the communal kitchen where food was
offered and shared among people of
different castes and religions
and when some of the local hindus called
for akbar in concern about this practice
he visited the sikh community but was
instead so pleased and impressed by the
practice of langar
that he offered lavish gifts to them
akbar also like
many of his successors on the throne
would also monetarily support
hindu temples across the empire it is
also said that he abolished the
so-called jazee attacks
that non-muslims were usually forced to
pay
for being a well for being non-muslims
these are just a few examples to show
the
attitude that akbar became so famous for
he was also actively interested and
engaged in
conversing and debating with them on
religious and spiritual matters
and this is where we get into the main
subject of today's video
indeed in the last decades of his life
akbar instigated a movement
of religious discussion and
inter-religious dialogue
that he himself would actively partake
in being so involved and personally
invested in spiritual matters
it is said that akbar would spend long
nights with
shishti masters discussing different
spiritual questions with them
after about a year of this akbar wanted
to take these discussions to a broader
level and decided to create a forum
where opposing ideas could be discussed
and debated formally
it is for these reasons that in 1576
he formed what he called the ibadathana
the house of worship
in connection to the shrine of a sufi
master of the shishti order
in the house of worship he would invite
people from different religious
traditions
first from different muslim
denominations so sunishia etc
but later also from all kinds of
religions that existed in the region
and had them engage in debates and
discussions
quote according to abu fazal akbar
invited sufis
philosophers or raiders jurists sunnis
shees
brahmanas jains christians of various
denominations
jews zoroastrians and still others to
the beautiful detached building of the
house of worship
and made a rigorous examination of the
principles of
all their faiths and creeds the astute
sovereign praised whatever was good in
any of these faiths and creeds
akbar personally took part in these
discussions it seems like he wanted to
find the
different commonalities and truths that
hid within the different religious
traditions
to find a kind of hidden universal truth
within
them all that transcended sectarian
divisions
this all sounds very nice of course but
the meetings themselves
usually ended in complete disasters
people starting to
insult each other and and fights
erupting during these
meetings so eventually these meetings
were disbanded
but by the end of this phase akbad had
come to some rather interesting
conclusions
according to sources it seems that he
had used these discussions as the basis
to create a syncretistic religious
movement of his own
which has become known as dinilahi or
the divine religion
it wasn't called this at the time by
akbar himself though but rather it was
called tauhidi
or divine monotheism now this is where
telling the story in an accurate way
becomes a little
difficult there are many different ideas
about what this divine religion was
supposed to be
some interpreted to have been an
entirely new religion created by akbar
that tried to syncretize and bring
together uh
aspects of all these different religions
in the region to create a new
universalist religion but others
disagree and instead interpret this dean
elahi
to be rather an extension of his already
existing sufi oriented islamic faith
akbar is and was accused of having
left islam completely as being an
apostate basically
and many historians today accept this as
basic fact
even though all those claims basically
come from akbar's enemies
certainly we cannot ignore the very
obvious fact that akbar was
interested in and influenced by
different religious traditions
like hinduism zoroastrianism and
christianity
many of the critical accounts tell of
how akbar would adopt various practices
from these religions like
that he would worship the sun that he
forbade the slaughtering of
cows and that he would shave the crown
of his head because
the buddhists thought that the soul
escaped from that part of the body
but these writers also kind of expose
themselves when they start to claim
things that are
well highly unlikely like for example
the claim that akbar supposedly
forbade all islamic practice in the
empire or that he
banned names like muhammad and ahmad as
already pointed out all these accounts
come from critical authors like al bada
yuni
who were very openly hostile towards the
emperor
and for that reason of course they
should be taken with a huge grain of
salt
we find no claims of apostasy from akbar
himself
or from his closest grand vizier abel
fazil
who instead writes quote a set of evil
thinking shameless ones
imagined that the prince of horizons
regarded the muslim religion with
disfavor
the sole evidence which those
wrong-headed ones whose understanding
was rusted
had for this was that the wise sovereign
out of his tolerant disposition
and general benevolence extensive
overshadowing received all classes of
mankind with affection
especially did he search for evidence in
religious matters from the sages of
every religion and ascetics of all
faiths
the dini-lahi only seems clearly like a
new religion
if we don't take into account the sufi
form of islam that akbar was so attached
to
which contains many of the teachings and
ideas that he presented
albeit in a less radical form of course
in another presentation quote the d
nilahi
was not a new religion it was a sufi
order with its own formula in which all
the principles enunciated are to be
found in the quran
and the practices of the contemporary
sufi orders
the deen was no religion outside of
islam nor cut out from it
and illaha never regarded it as a
separate religion
and elahan was often as orthodox as a
mullah
furthermore quote the practices which he
asked and illahan to follow
were mostly islamic in origin or had
precedence in the actions of one of the
renowned islamic monarchs or saints
so we have very clearly differing
accounts critical and hostile authors
like al-badayyoni
presents the dini-lahi as an entirely
new religion and thus paints akbar as an
apostate
who had left islam to create this new
religion
while others instead see the dinilahi as
an extension
of his already existing islamic faith
now one of the most interesting and
controversial aspects
of the deen illahi is akbar's own role
in this religious movement
there are accounts that the formula
there is no god but god and akbar is his
representative
was uttered by those close to him in the
court indeed some interpretations claim
that akbar went even further than this
by actually claiming divinity for
himself
this is most famously represented by the
fact that he had seals printed
with the phrase allahu akbar and asked
his subjects to preface
letters and writings with this phrase so
what's so strange about this you may ask
after all allahu akbar is a very common
proclamation in islam which means god is
greater or god is great
the thing is the phrase allahu akbar
can also mean god is akbar
this has led many to speculate and
assume that this was an expression of
akbar's view of himself as being
actually divine
and that the religion if it was a
religion of the deen illahi
had akbar himself as its god
so to say while others rather say that
no
the fact that it says allahu akbar is
meant in the conventional sense that it
has always been used
by muslims and i'll let you guys decide
what you
or where you stand on this particular
question
and that's the thing about akbar we
don't really know
for sure what was going on with him
don't let my skeptical attitude fool you
there is quite a possibility that he did
consider himself
to have left the religion of islam there
are sources that point in this direction
but personally i find myself more in the
other camp
who thinks we can't really trust the
hostile account
and that automatically pointing to
outside non-islamic
influences as soon as someone has open
tolerant and somewhat unusual views
kind of paints islam as a static
monolith that is only
narrowly represented by the stricter
conceived quote-unquote orthodoxy
as i talked about earlier we find many
of akbar's ideas already in sufism
which akbar was so devoted to indeed
engagement with other religions and an
open attitude to discussion across
religious lines
was not exactly unusual in india by the
time of akbar
many other muslim scholars and leaders
had also expressed similar ideas the
shishti masters mentioned earlier
became known for their generosity and
kindness to all peoples
and there were many others at this time
who discussed the relationship between
islam and hinduism for example
not only were hindus often seen as among
the people of the book the
kitab but also that it contains some of
the same monotheistic teachings as islam
albeit having been corrupted much like
religions like christianity and judaism
characters like krishna and rama were
seen as prophets of god
rather than as deities like for the
hindus
for example the sufi author abdulrahman
al-shishti
represents one of these people who in
his book mira
read translated and interpreted the
bhagavad-gita
as essentially an expression of toheid
or monotheism
especially as understood by the sufis
krishna here becomes a prophet much like
jesus or muhammad
who taught the same message of divine
unity
the great grandson of akbar himself
prince darashiko
had similar tendencies and all of this
will be discussed properly in a future
episode
even akbar's bitter enemy al-bada yuni
is said to have translated the
mahabharata and the ramayana
so what i'm saying is that these kinds
of ideas were in the air at the time
and akbad is as all human beings a
product of his time and place
but akbar of course can appear
especially radical in some ways
especially if it is true that he adopted
many practices from these various
religions
but what i'm saying is that we shouldn't
immediately discard his ideas as
non-islamic and thereby let his enemies
a particular group
define what islam is from a neutral
standpoint
which is what we strive for on this
channel akhbad and his tolerance and
openness
represents islam just as much as ahmed
sir hindi
or al badayuni did at least if we
operate from the assumption that he
didn't
leave the religion which of course is
still a very much
a real possibility because regardless of
your opinion about his religious
affiliations or
the question of whether or not he
started a new religion
you can't deny that akbar was a emperor
who showed at least relatively an
openness and respect to different
cultural and religious groups in his
empire this attitude and policy often
goes under the name of sullikul
a phrase meaning universal peace or
peace for all
from the contemporary accounts we can
clearly see that this was the approach
to religion
and rule that akbar wanted to and did
adopt as policy in his empire
abu fazel says quote the world lord
exercises world sway on the principle of
universal peace every sect can assert
its doctrine without apprehension
and everyone can worship god after his
own fashion
akbar's own son and the future emperor
jahangir
strengthens the argument he associated
with the good
of every race and creed and persuasion
and was gracious to all in accordance
with their condition
and understanding this was different
from the practice in other realms for in
persia
there was room for she is only and in
turkey india and turan
there were room for sunnis only this
policy of sulikul or peace for all
was an attempt to bring harmony and
peace to a very diverse empire
not without its political social reasons
of course but very successful
nonetheless
akbar's rule of mughal lands is seen as
one of the most prosperous in history
jalaladin akbar passed away on october
3rd
1605 after suddenly falling very ill
many think that he may have been
poisoned perhaps even by his own son
but even after his death akbar's legacy
and influence could not be escaped
he had established the mughal empire as
one of the major civilizations of his
day
his religious movement the dini lahi
didn't survive
after his death having only about 18
adherents
but his general attitude of tolerance
did continue with successive rulers that
followed him but perhaps the most direct
successor to akbar in terms of his
spiritual and intellectual curiosity and
religious dialogue
was his great-grandson a prince who
never
got the chance to become emperor himself
darashuku
a devoted sufi as well as heir apparent
to
shah jahan darashuko stood firmly within
the bounds of the religion of islam
while simultaneously exploring and being
in dialogue with hinduism
as another expression of monotheism and
represents a
similar open attitude to his great
grandfather
and that is darashuko which we will
focus on in the next video
in this series in the end akbar is
mostly not remembered for his
military victories he sought to bring
harmony and stability to his vast empire
through the policy of
sulikul universal peace and was arguably
very successful in the end perhaps it is
best to let the man himself
have the final word quote it is my duty
to be in good understanding with all men
if they walk in the way of god's will
interference with them would be in
itself reprehensible
and if otherwise they are under the
malady of ignorance and deserve
my compassion i'll see you next time
shout out to all my patrons who are
keeping this channel going i really
appreciate it so so much
i will leave links to that stuff in the
description and in the comments in case
anyone else is
[Music]
interested
[Music]
foreign